the general secretary of the tuc francis
o'grady someone i'm sure who has more
than a couple of views on the way in
which piano staff have been treated
francis lovely to see you and well let's
just start with that do you think that
the actions of piano ferries are are
illegal
we do and we also think it's one of the
most shameful uh incidents in british
industrial relations 800 loyal skilled
workers marched off the ferries with no
notice no consultation with their union
and sacked
by a company
that has treated them like dirt
we need
the government to answer some hard
questions here who knew what when from
the prime minister down but critically
we need action we want those 800 workers
reinstated to their jobs and given the
dignity of livelihoods that they deserve
if however the the actions of piano
ferries are as you say
where as you say illegal doesn't that
mean that there are avenues which can be
pursued we had the small business
minister paul scully on the program this
morning stating that they they needed to
do their due diligence they needed to
find out they needed to speak to piano
ferries but if that they hadn't acted
properly there would be the potential
for unlimited fines
i'm very disappointed that conservative
mps abstained on a labor motion last
night calling for emergency legislation
because the the truth is uh finding out
what happened after the event means
nothing unless those workers get their
jobs back now the government has got
plenty of leaders to pull
pno uh has been handed free ports worth
millions of pounds in britain
it sits on the transport department's
own advisory group a very powerful group
they're awarded licenses
tax allowances tax handouts from the
tonnage tax the government could suspend
their licenses and tell them unless they
reinstate those workers then they are
not welcome in britain there is plenty
that the government could and should be
doing now to make sure those workers get
their jobs back
and francis is there also the
possibility perhaps of of industrial
action you'll excuse me that i i'm not
as uh as clued up as penal fairies as
you obviously are does that 800
represent the totality of their uk
workforce or are there others unionized
others that might well come out on
strike in support of their former
colleagues
there is huge solidarity from the whole
trade union movement on this and we will
be looking at our options because
this has to be a turning point we've
seen you know uh through the pandemics
so many workers
were regarded as heroes
since the pandemic we've seen the rise
of fire and
re-hire where workers are sacked and
then re-employed on worst terms and
conditions
we've got zero hours a million workers
on zero hours contracts in this country
bogus self-employment umbrella companies
agencies behaving badly we need the
employment bill uh the prime minister
promised that britain would be the best
place in the world to work well try
telling that to p o workers we need an
employment bill that strengthens workers
rights but also respects union rights
this was a company that did not consult
with unions as they are required to do
by law the government has got to come
down on them like a ton of bricks and
employer m get away with treating
workers in this way well certainly we we
should hear more from the government
after that that that deadline passes
later today but just to pick up on on
one thing that you just said when you
say that the the tuc is is looking at
its options is it possible that we could
see some sympathetic strike action take
place that others will come out in
solidarity with their colleagues
well as you know neil we have some of
the most
draconian anti-trade union laws in this
country and of course that's one of the
reasons why bad employers like piano
think they can get away with this
uh you know in that we are banned from
taking solidarity action but i know
i was marching through the streets of
london yesterday with piano workers the
huge public support that there is for
this struggle and the government has got
to act it could solve this now by taking
firm action against piano and let's just
remember that piano is ultimately owned
by a royal dictator in dubai whose
company
dp world has made nearly three billion
pounds worth of profits they can afford
to pay the union rate for the job and
they should